-They love you. We love you.
Welcome to the show.
Thanks so much for coming on.
-Well, thank you
for not making me put
a toilet plunger on my head.
-Well, the night is young.
-I watched the segment.
I was like, "Oh, my God.
What does he do on this show?"
-He's a plumber in the --
I have -- I have
a thousand questions.
I wanted to ask you
a zillion things.
But, of course,
everyone's talking about this.
The biggest news story
right now. Trump got indicted.
-Yes.
-And is -- what do we know
so far and what do we think
is going to happen?
-Well, we don't know a lot
because the indictment
is still sealed.
-Right.
-But we've heard
that there are reports
there are as many as 30 charges
in the indictment.
It will be unsealed on Tuesday
afternoon, around 2:00, 2:15,
when former President Trump
will be arraigned,
which is an historic first.
It has never before happened
in the history
of the United States of America.
And he will be taken downtown
to be processed.
He will be fingerprinted.
They will take a mugshot.
[ Laughter ]
It is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is this a bizarre time to be --
You're premiering your show
on Monday.
-We are.
And it's an incredible
news cycle to be working in.
And, you know,
this show and this --
It's a brand-new
cable-news channel --
like we need another one.
I know.
Everybody's like,
"We got another one? Seriously?"
-Yeah.
-But it's a good one.
And -- And -- I promise.
Because I think right now
on cable news,
you see a lot of shouting
talking heads
on the far right
and the far left.
And I think the 80% of America
is in the middle somehow
in the forgotten majority.
-Yeah, and we get to see --
[ Applause ]
We get to see Elizabeth Vargas.
You are one of my favorites.
You are an incredible
journalist, award-winning.
Did you always want to be on TV?
Just hearing your voice,
by the way, I go --
I get chills. You're so good.
-[ Laughs ] You're so funny.
And you're so full of it.
Come on.
-I'm not. I swear!
I'm a giant --
By the way, backstage talking
is different than this voice.
-Oh, please. Anyway...
No, I did not always
want to be --
-That's not how
you talked backstage.
You're like, "Hi, Jimmy!"
[ Laughter ]
"Hi-eeeee!"
-I do not sound like a chipmunk.
-No.
But you're very professional.
No, you know how to do it.
This clip is going around
the Internet now.
This is from back
on the "Today" show in 1994.
-Oh, yeah.
-Everyone was trying
to figure out this new thing
called the Internet.
-Yeah.
-Take a look at you
and Bryant Gumbel
and Katie Couric
trying to figure out
what the Internet is.
-That little mark with the "A"
and then the ring around it.
-"At"?
-See, that's what I said.
-Mm-hmm.
-Katie said she thought
it was "about."
What is Internet anyway?
-Internet is that massive
computer network,
the one that's becoming
really big now.
A lot of people use it
and communicate.
I guess they can communicate
with NBC writers and producers.
Allison, can you explain
what Internet is?
[ Laughter ]
-"Can you explain
what Internet is?"
Isn't it wild to watch it now?
-That clip gets resurrected
about every four months
on Twitter and social media,
and people are like,
"Oh, my God!
Have you seen this?"
It was like,
"Yes, about 49,000 times."
-Yeah.
-But here's the funny story.
First of all, my kids --
I've got two teenage sons.
They took a look at it,
and they were like,
"Mom, you're the one
who's explaining
what the Internet is?"
-Yeah. "You know nothing
about the Internet!"
-Yeah.
-Yeah. That's so wild.
-But you know what?
BMW used that clip for a huge
Super Bowl commercial.
-Oh.
-And they cut me out!
[ Laughter ]
It was only Bryant and Katie,
and they got free BMWs.
-Wait! What?!
-I got completely shafted!
-We can make this --
No, we can make this all good.
BMW, if you're watching.
-Yes.
-First of all, I'm the one
who brought it up.
-Yes.
-So I think...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
And you all were here
to witness it.
You all deserve cars.
Everyone here deserves a BMW!
Come on! Make it right.
Make it right, BMW.
-You're the new Oprah.
-Thank you so much. Yeah.
-BMWs for everyone.
-Yeah.
No one's getting a car at all.
You know, we were talking
backstage and I go --
You know, you've interviewed
every single person
that I want to go --
There's such a giant list.
But I just picked two
that stuck in my head.
I go, "I'd love
to hear the story."
Tell me about when
you interviewed Mick Jagger,
who's one of my all-time faves.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Oh, you got the picture!
-Yeah, Look at --
-Yeah, look at that.
-[As Jagger] What was he like?
-You know, first of all,
he hardly ever gives interviews.
-No, he doesn't like
to talk with people. Yeah.
-I could have just
interviewed you.
-That's right. Where were we?
-You gotta get
a couple of wrinkles.
-Yeah. We got to do like that.
[Normal voice] What did you say
to him? Where were you?
-Well, here's the big thing.
We were both --
I was interviewing him in LA,
and I was staying in the
Four Seasons in Beverly Hills
in a tiny little room.
And he was staying at the
Four Seasons in Beverly Hills
in the massive
presidential suite,
which is the entire top floor
of the hotel.
-Yeah.
-And some producer in New York
who I didn't --
hadn't worked with before
decided to e-mail me,
fax me --
That was -- Fax me.
Some questions that she thought
would be good
to ask Mick Jagger.
-"What is the Internet?"
-I know.
"What is the Internet?"
-"What is a fax machine?"
-The concierge of the hotel
took them
and put them under Mick Jagger's
door instead of my door.
And the questions were bad.
And I was awakened
the morning of the interview
with a panicky phone call from
the booker in New York saying,
"You've got to go straight
away up to Mick Jagger's
presidential suite
and make this right
and tell him that this was
some rogue producer in New York
who didn't know
what she was doing."
-Because you're not even
allowed to give questions.
-No.
We never give questions out.
But I never -- I don't even
write down questions
when I do interviews.
I mean, I would never have
asked those questions
that were being faxed.
They were not good questions.
-Ooh.
-So they said, "You've got
to go up there right away,
and I was like, "Oh, my God."
-He canceled. He said --
[As Jagger] "I'm not doing it."
-So -- No.
That's what he said,
-"No way! Go away!"
-And so I go,
and I knock on the door,
and he answers the door,
and he's wearing
a silk kimono robe...
-[Normal voice]
Stop it. Come on.
-...that is open to his navel.
-Yeah! Yes!
'Cause he can do that!
Because he's Mick Jagger!
-Yes.
-I love that guy.
-Yes, he can.
-Yeah, he's a fashion icon.
I love it.
-Anyway, I had to go
into the suite,
which it took us five minutes
to walk through
all the many rooms
to finally get
to the living room
and sit down and convince him
to do the interview.
-And did he do it?
-He did it.
-Yeah. That's what I'm talking
about. 'Cause he's the best.
-Yeah.
And you got to see him
in a kimono. You got a story.
-He's really smart.
-Oh, he's brilliant.
-He's a really smart guy.
-Brilliant.
He knows exactly
what he's doing.
And then the other story
that -- It touched me, actually.
I thought it was beautiful,
this story.
You interviewed Joe Biden
before he was president.
-Right before he was president.
I have interviewed him
many times.
I interviewed him
and Lindsey Graham
in the green zone in Iraq,
in Baghdad during the war.
And that's when the two of them
were playing well together.
-Wow.
-But he wrote a beautiful book
called "Promise Me, Dad"
about his son Beau Biden
who died of brain cancer
and asked me to please
come down to Florida
and interview him in front of
a live audience, which I did.
And that's a picture
of us backstage.
And, of course, I was --
At the end of the interview,
I had to ask, are you
going to run for president?
And it was right before
he went back up to Delaware
to meet with the family
and decide.
But he was great
because he went --
he came backstage afterward
and he said --
And he spent a lot of time
talking, and he said,
"Can I call your sons?"
And I was like, "What?"
And he said, "Hand me your
phone. Call your son."
-So I called my son Zachary.
And he spoke for 15 minutes
on the phone,
first with my son Zachary,
and then with my son Sam,
basically saying, you know,
"Thank you for letting your mom
come down here tonight
and interview me.
and giving her up
for a school night,"
because it was a school night.
And, you know,
"I'd like to take you out
for a Coke next time
I'm in New York."
Like, yeah, right.
-Are you going to be
interviewing people
on the news show?
-Oh, yes.
It's mostly interview-driven.
We're going to take --
It's an hour-long show
from 6:00 to 7:00
East Coast time.
And we're gonna take the
handful of the biggest stories
and go really deep on them.
And I love doing
live interviews, Jimmy.
It's my favorite part
of my job.
So I don't want to do just --
you know, be a prompter jockey,
as they call it,
when you just do nothing
but read story, story, story.
-So on Monday
we're gonna see you live.
-Yeah, we've got a lot of great
guests on Monday night already.
I'm afraid to tell
because I don't want to jinx it.
-[As Jagger] No. You don't have
to tell. We all know who it is.
Hey! Remember me?!
I'm wearing a kimono!
Hello! Remember me? Hey!
-He's never gonna
talk to me again
now that I told that story.
-He will. He will. I love you.
Congratulations.
Good luck on everything.
Elizabeth Vargas, everybody.
-Thank you.
-"Elizabeth Vargas Reports"
premieres Monday at 6:00 p.m.
on NewsNation.
More "Tonight Show"
after the break. Stick around.